انا انا الاسد اسد انا انا الاسد انا
الاسد ملك الغابه ذو اقدام ومهابه انا
الاسد ملك الغابه ذو اقدام ومهابه اني
اقوى الحيوانات
تحسبوني زائير حسابه اني اقوى الحيوانات
تحسب لسئير حسابا انا الاسد انا الاسد انا
الاسد انا الاسد انا الاسد انا الاسد انا
الاسد
اهو الذ الادغال فيفر الكل بالحال احيا من
حولي لبؤات تلهو من حول الاشبال بزئير اعز
الادغال فيفر الكل وبالحال احيا من حولي
لبؤاتي تلهو من حول الاشبال اسد اسد انا
الاسد اسد اسد انا انا الاسد انا مفترس
انا صياد
ومزاجي لو اغ
ضب اتجول ارض
السافانا مع عائلتي كالمعتاد انا مفترس
انا صياد ومزاجي لو اغ
اتجول ارض السافانا مع عائلتك المعتاد انا
الاسد ملك الغابه ذو اقدام ومهابه
الاسد ملك الغابه ذو اقدام ومهابه اني
اقوى الحيوانات
تحسب لزائري حسابك اسد اسد انا الاسد اسد
اسد انا انا الاسد
انياب ضخمه وقويه اخضع لي تلك البريه لكن
عائله الاصليه
وفصيله جنس القططيه انيابي ضخمه وقويه
اقطعوا لي تلك البريه لكن عائلتي الاصليه
وفصيله جنس القطط يه اسد اسد انا الاسد
اسد اسد انا انا الاسد اسد اسد انا الاسد
الاسد اسد انا انا الاسد